[Music]
all right y'all
welcome and here we go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to episode 168
of your absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
anyway y'all welcome back to the podcast
turn the mic down
welcome back today we talk about a lot
of stuff
nfl playoffs
is cowboys the americas team
book of boba fett
season finale of ocean's uh station 11
and two movies that i saw on the
airplane
wrath of a man with jason statham
and the movie old by m night shyamalan
but welcome back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
anyways welcome back to riffing with
griffin y'all uh if you're here live
we're doing it live it's monday live
because i was in
where was i i was in uh grand rapids
michigan shout out to grand rapids
michigan uh it was pretty good had a
little drama
some some drama unfolded but you know
what
i'm not even gonna talk about it i know
how that spoiler i shouldn't have even
said that right now you're gonna be
thinking about it all day what was the
jabba but yeah it's whatever it is what
it is
all i'll say is this some jealous
boyfriends were out in full effect but
anyways
um
welcome back to the show y'all um for
everybody uh if you're in canada
edmonton area
uh this week starting thursday i'm gonna
be at the
um
comic strip in mall of america in
edmonton
so come check me out all my canadian
fans excuse me and as always uh daily
i'm on uh twitch
at eric griffin gaming so come check me
out at eric griffin gaming i love the
gaming i have to play call of duty oh i
saw in like i saw a thing somebody
tweeted at me that like like it was like
november or something like that i was
like the um
what do you call it uh
like 140th
most
watched like uh call of duty streamer
and i know that seems like 140 but i
believe there's like 10 000
so i felt like i was up there uh hello
daniel miranda who's like notice me in
the chat you guys are just
monsters man but welcome if you're
watching me live um this week i had to
leave on a wednesday and i got to leave
on a wednesday today too so i couldn't
do a bonus episode last week but i am
gonna try to i'm not gonna try i'm gonna
do it i'm gonna do a bonu when i'm in
town i'm gonna do a bonus live episode
but to re-watch it it'll be on the
patreon so you can still catch it live
but if you miss it if you want to be a
part of my patreon i'll be doing and
that's why i just i could delve into
like
my it might be only 30 minutes but i
might delve into like an old movie an
old show
you know really get into some topic uh
uh in the entertainment that i really
want to get into so
anyways um i still got the yeah somebody
see you see me i'm still coughing a
little bit
you know what that is is uh see even
before um
covid i had
a sinus issue that every year around a
certain time the doctor tells me the
same thing i don't drink enough water
and my my sinus post the sinus drip is
causing me to cough and so it's like i
have to have a humidifier going and i
have to make sure to stay hydrated and
then that clears that out and so it's
just on top of you know
having that happen to me you know so
it's hard you know and right now in this
day and age it's
you can't have bodily functions near
people because they just start people
act crazy you know what i
all mean and i got to give a public
shout out to rachel
who i was out in grand rapids
and
i opened up my suitcase rachel helps me
pack sometimes and she's i love when she
helps me pack because she gives me the
proper amount of underwear she makes
sure i have all the stuff that i need
so i didn't and i said well my bags here
just take whatever out of it right
that's what i said something like that
i get to grand rapids and i have this
bag
this is my bag right here actually i
have it right here because this is where
it was this is from when i oh that's
actually patrick stewart this is a bag i
got when i was on uh blunt talk on stars
with patrick stewart
so
that's has all my stream gear in it you
know it has my like capture cards and
all the you know the chords and stuff
that i use so i can stream when i'm on
the road and my picture comes up on the
screen and all that stuff
i open the bag and it's not in there and
i instantly blame rachel i'm like rachel
and i hit her up and i'm like where's my
stream stuff and she's like oh i'm so
sorry whatever so when i get home
and i even made the title of my streams
like forgot you know just don't have my
stream stuff and i'm not gonna mention
whose fault it is you know just implying
that it was her fault well when i get
home when i look under my desk i realize
that i took my stream bag out and i put
it underneath my desk
[Laughter]
so public apology it was not her fault
this was all my fault uh you know and
that's why i have this beautiful picture
up as my background for the beginning of
the podcast which is just
you know
rachel
on the beach at adam devine's wedding
so shout out to her wasn't your fault
babe it was all me
so anyways guys um
there is one thing i want to talk about
before i get into everything i wanted to
talk about today
one of the gifts i got from myself this
year for christmas and rachel was simply
for the house
so we have three bathrooms you know
because and uh
i got us
some bidets
you know
some fancy toilet seats that you hook on
and you know they even has you have to
plug them in because it has like a
remote control too and on a remote
control you have like a seat warmer
you know
where you want to wash front back
a fan
so you could turn on the fan adjust the
pressure they have all these little
great excuse me settings on the thing
and i got two of them
and they weren't cheap
so i got two of them and i put them in
like the master bedroom and i put it in
the bathroom that's on the second floor
that i you know that i use most of the
time you know what i mean
but here's what i want to say
when we gonna stop acting like bidet's
work okay let's just
can we put that out there into the
universe
why are we pretending like bidets work
like here's what i mean by that
i don't care what you say
i don't care how long you sit on that
thing with the water splashing on you i
don't care how long you do it for
don't think that you don't still
have to do some cleanup okay that's all
i'm saying
like don't think like with this one you
can wash
and then turn the fan on
and then think you can just get up and
walk away
uh-uh
that ain't true man
and i'm at an age where
the the cleanup is usually longer than
the delivery
okay let's just i'm gonna say it like
that right so this thing is
ridiculous man like
some i don't i'm trying not to be
graphic okay because you know what i
mean but like
you wat you splash you wash you sit
there for a second and sometimes i'm the
and and let's be honest too i mean
it's more like sometimes i'm sitting
there like ooh stop flirting with me but
dang you know what i mean because you
know it'd be hitting you good are you
like oh man what is this uh sensation
okay so other than that
you know you sit there i don't care for
how long you sit there maybe a minute
how long ever long you want to be doing
it but i don't care what you do when
it's time for the wipe
it's like
nothing happened it's like the thing
didn't do nothing and you still end up
doing the same amount like they give you
this lie that like oh you're going to be
saving toilet paper you're going to be
saving the environment no you not
because now you got to use this sucker
to not only clean but dry you have to
dry off too because you soaking wet with
booty juice okay and it's just i don't
know
i just think like this is a sham like
bidets are a fraud okay
unless you got some high-powered one
that could take paint off a a battleship
unless unless you have one of those this
sucker just i'm just telling you it
don't work properly i'm just throwing
that out there so i i just want to know
in the comments right now like why do we
like
what's your experience
have you have you had the experience
where you were like hey this actually
works pretty good or you know or if you
are you are you like me where you're
like well damn what did it actually do
so that's gonna be uh from the comment
thread
this week man because i don't know oh
man all right um i i think i had a
couple of comments i wanted to look at
from last week's episode
um let me let let me see here
um
because of what because one of the shows
i want to talk about is stations 11 and
like somebody tony c six days ago wrote
i watched six episodes of station eleven
it's fascinating but i couldn't tell you
why i have no idea when it's go where
it's going with the story but but like i
can't wait to finish tomorrow thanks for
bringing it to my attention
that is the best example of that show
like that is such a great comment about
that show so i appreciate that
comment right there
i got a lot of stations 11 is great
comments
and um uh anyways you know when i go to
that review i'll talk about that but
let's get into let's get into it this
week i got no ads this week um which is
uh good for i don't know good or bad who
knows but let's get into uh this week
what i wanted to talk about first is the
nfl playoffs let's talk about the
playoffs man um i'm a i'm a
i'm a i'm more of a football band fan
now these days even more than i am a
basketball fan and i know that's crazy
because i had season tickets to the
clippers but something about the
pandemic and what i wanted to watch and
why i wanted to watch it really changed
and i feel like and the nfl
the sport
football itself is such an engaging
sport and it's really great on tv you
know what i mean it's really great on tv
to watch football because you get it in
doses it's like they let you set up
you're like okay okay oh now it's time
to watch
there's the play and then when it ends
you can kind of space out and you're
just like okay and then you're listening
to the announcers tell you things you
can get yourself set up again for the
next play as opposed to like basketball
where the action is continuous and
ongoing in spurts of two three five
minutes at a time sometimes
you know but then sometimes you just
lose interest because it's just not
exciting or there's nothing on the line
excuse me during the regular season so
you're just kind of like is this
exciting what does it mean to me i just
football has a more
ingrained uh feeling of fandom because
like you know especially if you watch
college sports and you know these people
then they move on and then you know it's
kind of sort of city pride you can't
really see the players faces so it's
more about the team than it is about
individuals so footballs a really
engaging sport and the best time of year
is right now in the playoffs man so
first round of the playoffs are almost
done
tonight we got the niners and uh
cardinals uh you know i'm pulling for
the
49ers because you know not 49ers not i
said that wrong rams into cardinals i'm
sorry rams and the cardinals are tonight
and i'm looking forward to that and i
want the rams to win
but i'll get to that i'll get to my
predictions later so what i'll say first
about this nfl playoffs is this is
probably the most exciting nfl playoffs
that we've had in a long time
there isn't really a clear favorite and
every single one of these teams that are
left legit has a chance to win the super
bowl and you kind of sit there and look
and go i actually don't know who's
really going to win or who has the
ability to win because there's so many
like teams that got something great
about them something that you can
question about them but they all got
that so what we got left now is
so kansas city beat like the teams that
the first round was kind of like
whatever because we had to get rid of
these teams that really legit didn't
have a shot they snuck into the playoffs
and we needed to get rid of them so
so see ya thanks for coming out but you
got to get the hell out of here and that
was the pittsburgh steelers pittsburgh
steelers snuck in
shout out to mike tomlin one of the best
coaches ever he's never had a losing
season wrap your brain around that
in 15 years he's never had a losing
season and if you watch football you
know how difficult that is that's it's
an amazing stat hasn't won the super
bowl a lot just one time but still a lot
of teams have never won or have only won
one in in 50 years right so it is what
it is so steelers had to go good
riddance ben roethlisberger you had a
really great career but you should have
retired like four years ago
all right then we had the bills first
the patriots i kind of wanted the
patriots to win but
no rookie quarterback has ever won the
super bowl matt jones is great but he's
a rookie he plays like a rookie but
kudos to bill belichick for getting his
team to 10 wins they won 10
games the patriots after only winning
seven last year with cam newton and all
that drama with covet and eight players
leaving the team because of kovit he he
spent money in free agency and turned
this franchise back around where they
there was one point in the season where
they were the top of the afc that is
amazing and it's a testament to his
coaching shout out to bill belichick and
the patriots and look out for them in
the future i feel like in the next two
three years they're gonna be legit super
bowl contenders so we needed to get rid
of them though and the bills showed up
bills showed up well what's the
quarterback's name for the bills um um
josh allen
dude showed up five touchdowns in that
game put a stamp on it like yo i am to
be feared so that was great
okay then you have my raiders and the
cincinnati uh um cincinnati bengals okay
i wanted the raiders to win and kudos to
the raiders organization with all of the
turmoil and drama that they had this
year for them to be in the playoffs and
win 10 games was just amazing duis uh
murder uh you know not you know
somebody a loss of life the john gruden
situation and for them to turn that
around and show like yo we actually are
a good team we just you know that
organization is looking good for the
future depending on who they get and i
hope they get harbaugh from michigan i
hope they steal haul ball from michigan
because that guy knows how to turn
something around but one of those teams
needed to get out of there and it
probably was the raiders i don't think
the [ __ ] the raiders legit had a
chance to win the super bowl and then
you got cincinnati with joe cool joe
burrow that dude is the business okay
i'm just telling you right now joe
burrow is the business he will be an mvp
and he might lead this team to the
championship he got that thing man he
got that thing he got it he got that it
factor so and i still feel like they
could go on a run and have a legit shot
at the super bowl so now we got the
teams left they got a legit shot so
number one seed tennessee after losing
derrick henry uh they they plowed along
and and ended up with the number one
seed in the afc tough thing to do with a
team like kansas city in there with the
bills in there you know what i mean they
did it so they fought for and earned the
number one seed so now we're getting
into the real games okay so like i said
if cincinnati are they ready right now
if they are they got this is how they
can show it they gotta beat tennessee
and then the next thing you know we
talking about freaking
you know joe burrow like putting his
team in
after
tearing his acl and not playing all of
last year to coming back the way he's
playing right now
look out for them but if tennessee wins
again it shows they are legit derrick
henry's back they got that smash mouth
style they got a quarterback that
doesn't make a lot of mistakes in ryan
tannehill so we'll see what happens with
that and then on the other side we got
the game this is the game all the rest
of these games don't matter this one is
the game kansas city versus buffalo this
is it right here
okay
kansas city are you a dynasty can you
give back to the super bowl can you
actually win it is your team and cause
they are playing great right now like
nine games in a row they won or
something like that eight or nine
no no they lost but they lost to uh no
they won like eight out of nine or
something like that
um
and then you guys said then you got
buffalo is it buffalo's time
excuse me josh allen was a super uh mvp
candidate last year but you know he
didn't follow through he just
something happened in the playoffs so
his first round he beats bill belichick
let's build better check no i'm here to
stay all right and now he's gotta if
they can get past kansas city
look out for but i think i think if
buffalo gets past kansas city
they go into the super bowl all right
that's my predict that's my first
prediction right there
if buffalo gets past kansas city they go
into the super bowl all right but if
kansas city wins
i think they can still lose to tennessee
or cincinnati that's my prediction there
all right
so
there you go
that's in the afc now in the nfc you got
green bay i think i
my prediction i would like to see this
is what i would like to see i would like
to see
the green bay packers win the super bowl
because i just like uh i like aaron
rodgers i like his swag i like his
nonsense i like everything about aaron
rodgers and how he carries himself i
didn't like how he like that that whole
vaccination nonsense but i like since
then how he's owning it okay and uh i
like that i i and i like when people go
through turmoil and turn it around and
win and i'm petty too i'm petty like
aaron rodgers you know they drafted his
successor without his didn't talk to him
about it the drafted a dude that ain't
good sorry jordan love you ain't it
right you will never be it not in this
league not with the no i'm saying not
with the green bay packers you ain't it
they figured that out early then the
dude comes back and aaron rodgers is
like oh you want to draft oh you want to
draft my successor okay let me give you
an mvp season bow
then he turns around after all this
nonsense in the off season and then he
comes around again and goes oh after
that first game everybody was like oh oh
the saints put the whooping on them and
and everybody was like oh then aaron
rodgers was like all right okay here you
go guys and he gives you another mvp
caliber season and he white he might win
the mvp again wow all right so i would
like to see that so now they're playing
the niners and the niners were the
little darling pick that everybody
wanted to see
uh beat the cowboys and we're gonna get
to the cowboys all right
you know what i mean and we're gonna get
to the cop because the cowboys and
niners this is that game where neither
one of these teams legit had a shot to
win the super bowl i never believed in
the cowboys but we'll get to that and
then the niners like you know there's no
way if they make a run to the super bowl
that would be amazing kudos to uh jimmy
garoppolo right but like
everybody picked the niners to beat the
cowboys i mean you know what i mean so
beating the cowboys and the niners tried
to give the game back like jimmy
garoppolo all they had to do was get
down kick a field goal this game's over
or hit or maybe get a touchdown and it's
really over and they found a way to give
dallas an opportunity but dallas is so
stupid that they squandered that
opportunity three passes in a row they
go 40 yards and get out of bounds and
then with 10 seconds left or something
he wants to run a quarterback sneak and
then doesn't do the right thing in the
end and then the time runs out what a
way to lose so the niners sneak past
them but i just do not see that now i i
think the green bay packers are gonna
put the whoop on the niners right but in
the nfl it's just one day one game you
know what i mean so you never know but i
do think the green bay packers are gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of them all right so
then you have this other game all right
uh the cardinals
and the rams which is tonight and this
is one of these this is the situation
where these are these fringe contenders
now in the beginning of the year they
seem like real super contenders
especially the rams but then rams and
matthew stafford they kind of floundered
through the season so it's hard to see
like how good are they like he has a lot
to prove matthew stafford everybody
blamed detroit that he's a really great
but
it was only because he was in detroit
but you know what you you haven't proved
that it was because of detroit starting
to feel like it was because of you bruh
because of you you had calvin johnson a
first ballot hall of fame receiver and
you couldn't win a playoff game now you
out here with this
super talented team man on offense and
defense you got your dude cooper cup
broke the records you know you got this
is an amazing team they got and you seem
to be the weak link so he's got a lot to
prove
and to get back on track on being a
super bowl contender and then the winner
of that game will play
the tampa bay
and so you know so tampa bay put the
whoop on um
the cardinals i'm not the cardinals um
the eagles which they of course like the
eagles never had a shot kudos for them
for even being in the playoffs and
making it that far you know what i mean
like good like like
uh to the you know you know what i mean
jason j what's his name jason hurst or
what's his first name jalen hurst i
think it's jalen hurst
kudos to him man they they sent carson
wentz packing because the guy sucks and
then they got this like you know guy who
like he lost his job in the championship
game and he had to transfer and he's a
survivor and here he is he got his teams
in the playoffs they had a great finish
to the season so now they're going to be
battling with the cowboys for the leader
of the nfc east with this the worst
conference in all of football okay
so
they had didn't have a chance so tampa
bay did what they're supposed to do now
we got to see if tampa bay can get past
either the cardinals or the rams i think
i don't think tampa bay has it anymore i
think robert on county rob gronkowski is
a hamstring away from like you know
getting hurt and then that's it for them
they don't got antonio brown and they
needed him in my opinion one of their
receivers the big time receiver is still
hurt they're still they're banged up and
and brady's 44. so let's just see what
happens there but i don't think they
have a chance but you know you never
know with brady how many times people
counted brady out and he still made it
to the you know he makes it so that's
what i'm saying is super exciting i
don't know what i want to see but i
would like to see i would like to see
green bay rams but i would still love to
see green bay tampa bay in the nfc
championship game too so there you go so
that's my thoughts on the nfl playoffs
so now let's get to
let's get to this this next one here
let's talk about let's talk about them
cowboys
how about them cowboys
bro
cowboy fans
hey
stop talking about your cowboys
uh your cowboys suck man they've sucked
for 27 years let me say that again
they have sucked
for 27
years
when we gonna stop talking about
the cowboys like they america's team
can we stop it already
can we stop it
if anything's america's team it would be
the patriots
they won
seven super bowl six super bowls in this
time frame
i'm so sick of hearing about the cowboys
this like i like look kudos to dak
prescott he seems like a cool dude i
like his swag i like how he like talks
at the podium
but my i
as a casual nfl fan
he ain't it
okay that's just how i feel about it he
ain't it
and because he's got that star on his
back everybody wants to
like give him excuses
give him excuses and i'm like nah man
this guy's he's
he's just a really good quarterback but
he's no joe burrow
like who would you take moving forward
this is for the comments too guys
who do you think moving forward if you
had to pick between
dak prescott or jimmy garoppolo which
one of those guys do you think you go
all right i'm good with this guy i think
they're i think they're the exact the
same they're the exact same amount of
inconsistent you know they're the exact
same amount of like sometimes you go wow
that guy is great look what he did and
then he misses the pass in the super
bowl
you know you know what i mean like
and dak the same thing just when you go
wow 450 yards then you go oh but that
was against the giants or something you
know it's like there's always like
it's just something about dak prescott
that's not enough
maybe he'll prove to be like a better
player eventually but right now he ain't
it man
and the cowboys ain't it and i'ma tell
you why then we gonna move on
i'ma tell you why
just because of jerry jones and his
arrogance okay
when jerry jones fired jimmy johnson
the organization has never been the same
so because of your arrogance you got one
super bowl without jimmy johnson even
though that was his team
they were coming off a championship
and you
fire him because y'all didn't get along
and you won another one but that was it
and that's been the curse ever since
he never should have fired jimmy johnson
he should have he should have backed
away and let the man do what he does
because look what he did for that
organization trading herschel walker uh
and getting like 13 you know getting all
the picks and
and players that he got for that
changed the organization around into a
championship team again
and it's never been the same for
27
years
garbage
and i'm just trying to say i'm tired of
you i'm tired of dallas cowboy fans
you know it's just like what do you have
to what do you have to show like when
you watch espn and these things and you
see all these ex-cowboy players
like you know on tv trying to hype up
the cowboys they get excited every
single year they're like oh man
we got the defense now we got the
receivers we got this we got that we got
this and you think to yourself like all
right maybe they're right and every
single year the cowboys
fail
and so at a certain point that's who
they are
that's who they are until they're not
but i'm not believing in this team
ever again
until they actually do it
i don't care how good their regular
season is because you can always pick it
apart they play in the nfc east which is
terrible apparent i saw a stat today
that like dak is like he's got a great
record against the nfc east but a losing
record against every other thing well
come on man
at a certain point you got to win big
games and do big things you know what
i'm saying
yuck but anyways
so my prediction
um
oh man this is tough
but i think it's gonna be
i think after everything
i think it's gonna be the the chiefs
and green bay in a championship and
state farm would love that wouldn't they
like if you get the chiefs
first to green bay
that will be like
how we we wanted kobe and lebron to face
off each other in the championship like
it is really a shame that we never got
that that is the big huge loss in our
sports life
that lebron and kobe didn't play each
other in the championship at least one
time that really would have been
fantastic right and we never got that so
let's get this because to me
kudos to tom brady from winning seven
championships and being the guy that he
is much respect no shade on him but
those that
i would i would take aaron rodgers i
think aaron rodgers is a better
quarterback and i think if aaron rodgers
just had even one more super bowl
he already you could be like okay we'll
take aaron rodgers now but because this
dude has seven it's hard to argue right
but i think aaron rodgers
excuse me is in a position right now to
win two more super bowls he's playing
that good
there's a lot of parody in the league i
think he can really shine right now
you know and by the way if i was dallas
i would i would be like yo you want that
uh we'll take aaron rodgers off your
hands and you take dak
you know what i mean we'll take aaron
rodgers we'll pay this contract you know
what i mean all this stuff and then uh i
don't know
we'll see
but that's how i feel about that so
there you go that's what i know that was
a big sports chunk that most people that
listen to the podcast i know i don't
normally talk sports this much but that
was exciting i had to get get into it
all right let's get into the hollywood
portion of riffing with griffin let's go
into episode three of book of boba fett
all right
episode two
i thought was the best one so far
because it had this kind of off story it
was its own standalone story about the
uh the desert tribe whatever those
people are called
and like how you know how he was
interacting with them i thought that was
good
anytime they in tattooween
and and and boba fett is like trying to
be this crime lord
i i it's something dull about it
it's something i don't really like about
it and i'm gonna tell you why it don't
make sense to me so like in the show
people are coming to talk to boba fett
and they're all like yeah people don't
respect you
but you know what
why would they
if you think about it he got two pig
guys
bad [ __ ] asian girl
and him
that's his crew
why is he running the city
like
why is boba fett in charge of the city
and that's the only people he has i
don't know why the mayor didn't get
together like 10 12 15 20 guys on his
payroll
yeah go down to that old job of the hut
palace and bring me boba fett's head
that should have already happened i
don't understand why people are bowing
down to this guy and he only got four
people on the payroll right
all right so then now
so now he goes to um so now he's in the
city so some okay in episode three right
uh uh this dude comes
and he's all like yo
you know people are these this this gang
is stealing
my my goods all right i need you to
you're supposed to protect me i'm paying
for protection protect me so now boba
fett goes down
and i'm this took me out of it it took
me out of the star wars universe
completely because
they had
a bunch of teenage kids that look like
they should be on melrose place
okay they look like they were it looked
like a mtv real world cast
on some like stupid speeders that look
like vespas
it just took me so out of the star wars
universe that i was like this don't feel
right it didn't feel right it didn't
look right i thought it was i didn't
like the art design i didn't like the
acting of the people because they didn't
feel otherworldly all these people just
felt like this was like a supposed to be
in like los angeles or something and
this is some like street gang in los
angeles and they should have just been
like they should have been dancing or
something or they should have been like
it looked like bring it on or it looked
like um
what are those show what's those movies
where they dance it's like damn there's
always a dance competition and there's
kids from the street and they gotta go
dance off you know what i mean it just
and what's his name um um uh um um
the male stripper movie guy is in it you
know what i mean i
i just
i don't know man it i didn't believe it
dude
i did i just i didn't believe it it took
me out of it and so anyway so boba fett
goes to this street gang and he's all
like what are you guys doing and then
the girl's the leader and she's talking
smack and then he goes you know what
um
you know what he's like yeah you know
you're gonna come work for me and now
they're and now they're all of a sudden
loyal to him i'm like what i just
episode three lost me
channing tatum thank you channing tatum
he was in these movies and it was a step
up thank you thank that's why i like
doing it live because you guys helped me
out step up it felt like step up it felt
like sp step up nine in space that's
what book of boba fett episode three
felt like step up nine in space like if
boba fett would have started singing for
some reason that would have been great
and magic mike is the movie thank you i
feel like i'm getting old um
yeah dude he was like
somebody said break into electric
boogaloo exactly
this felt like boba fett electric
boogaloo that's what it felt like man it
was just so cheesy and corny so thumbs
down on episode three of uh uh book of
boba fett man
i just could i couldn't
i couldn't like i couldn't get involved
with it man it just so hopefully episode
four they're gonna get better i got my
mandalorian shirt on so i still do
believe in the dis in uh star wars
universe so
we'll see about that
um next show which i talked about
earlier um
stations 11.
guys
i'm not usually pretentious i'm not
usually artsy fartsy i'm more common
sense i just want things to make sense
but i gotta tell you this show
is fantastic man
it's so artistic
the performances are so grounded and
real
and the last episode of stations 11 was
just
i'm telling you i don't say this often
but it was a masterpiece
this show is a masterpiece and i
couldn't tell you what the hell it's
about
you know what i mean like that's
you know and
they they make reference to shakespeare
a lot in this movie they're always
talking about hamlet
and i have no idea what hamlet's about
i'm not a shakespeare guy but
there's something beautiful about it man
and this final episode they do this
scene from shakespeare within this the
show and
i don't know i was tearing up and
you know people re reconnected that
haven't you know that in the story have
been lost for years and they finally
reconnected and it just was like it was
so beautiful
um i just i really recommend
you need to
uh watch this show man watch it with an
open mind open heart just kind of watch
it and just and you're just following
people
in a story about life like if this would
have because in the story for the people
just watching for the first time and you
don't even know what stations 11 is
about but it's like this
post-apocalyptic like there was a flu
that ravaged the world and it was a kind
of flu that was actually deadly you know
what i mean like you know so like the
whole population is most of the
population is wiped out and this is the
remnants of the population of what's
left and that girl right there who's uh
she plays mckenzie i forgot her name um
i should have looked it up uh but
whatever her name is i've talked about
it before she's doing such a great job
and you kind of follow her as she grows
up in this world so that so like they
always do like time jumps so they'll
time jump back and be like this is year
one and then like so then in year 20
she's a part of this
traveling troupe of actors and and they
have like this thing they call the wheel
and it's just a map of like communities
and they go around the community
communities and they perform shakespeare
for these communities
to give people art and they got horses
and they just travel around and they set
up camp and it's just a story about the
people in this community and how they
got there and what they're doing like
there's no real big like uh point of the
plot of being like oh they have to like
blow up the death star or some you know
you know how like stuff has plots like
that no this is just about watching
people deal with
tremendous life situations and
it's really great so i can't endorse
this show enough
um but check out
stations 11
on hbo max if you can
so
yeah
there's uh my stations 11
review all right so now
i want to talk about these two movies
that i watched on the the airplanes this
week
one of them is called wrath of a man
okay wrath of a man and it's directed by
guy richie so when i saw it now
jason statham movies
um
jason stay some stay some movies
uh
they're all the same to me and they're
actually my guilty pleasure
they remind me of
jet li movies like i used to like
anytime a jetly movie would come out i
would go watch it because it would
always be the same thing it's good kung
fu
his broken english but like the fighting
is so good and it's always the same
thing like you know there's there's
somebody doing something bad and then
he's just there trying to mind his own
business and they drag him into it when
he doesn't want to be dragged into it
and he has to fight his way out and he
becomes the hero right
so
that's jason statham too like there's
like 10 jason statham movies that are
all the same he's like a dad who lives
on a farm or something and like he's got
a daughter and you know or something
like that and then like some bad people
are trying to do things and he's telling
them don't get me involved in this you
don't want to see me mad or like or like
you know he's some ex you know rambo
type guy who's just trying to live his
life and then he gets dragged into a
situation there's like 10 jason statham
movies that are just like that
so when i saw this one i was like oh
this is gonna be another one of these
movies i can't wait to watch it but then
i saw it was directed by guy richie
now guy richie
this dude is pretty dope man as a
director and storyteller you know what i
mean like he's done snatch and he's just
done a lot of like
uh really you know
interesting movies you know what i mean
so
when i saw him i was like i wonder how
this is going to go so i'm not going to
recap wrath of the man but it's like
you know it's a it's a revenge story
very much but i highly rec i recommend
it it's actually very enjoyable movie uh
how it was executed i like the artsy
fartsiness of it but you know jason
statham plays like a crime boss
who has a tragedy happen to him and this
is like how he seeks revenge
uh and you learn how how guy richie
tells the story you kind of get
information as it goes along until
you're finally in the end where you see
how it all comes about and at the end of
the movie i was like very much like oh
this was actually pretty good i was i
was pleased with it so
yeah man check out uh wrath of a man i
saw it on an airplane like it's an old
movie actually but it just started to
come i think it's just coming out on
like cable and all that kind of stuff or
you know wherever you like streaming i
don't know why i say cable that just
aged myself but
wherever you get streaming movies that
have just come out this one was actually
uh pretty good
yeah so uh you know this guy richie
movie because that came out it was in
theaters may 7th it says so you know
that's a while ago but this this
actually turned out to be a pretty good
movie all right dude now spoiler alert
i'm about to do that thing that i do
when i watch a movie that like either
it's so weird that i'm a recap it like
tentian or it's so terrible like fast
and furious nine that i have to like
talk about talk about the movie from
beginning to end and that's what we'll
be about to do to finish the podcast
with old
old
uh bobby lee called me
and was like yo have you seen old
on and i was like no he was like you
have to watch it it's one of the worst
movies i've ever seen in my life and i
was like oh i love that so when somebody
says that i'm like especially coming
from bobby i gotta watch it
okay i gotta watch it so old
m night shyamalan is back again
back again
this guy i think m like shyamalan has
shot his wad i think he's done you know
i don't know but i shouldn't even say
that because i do like servant on apple
he's a part of servant and i like
servant but did but his movies i don't
know what's going on dude i mean you got
the top three for me for him are six
cents
obviously
um the village and some people are iffy
on the village i really enjoyed the
village and then it's um uh what's the
other one um uh with uh uh
um uh morgan freeman um
what is that freaking why am i
forgetting and they just did a sequel
which was terrible but um
unbreakable there you go those are the
three that like i think
that's it for him and then and then he's
tried to recap capture that magic ever
since but old man i mean it stars a
plethora of people
gail garcia who actually is in
he's in station's 11 which is a really
good show
it's just a bunch of people
so let's just recap old y'all
all right so old opens up
old up is up with just family
mother and father and two kids or is it
three kids do they got three kids two
kids and obviously the mother and father
are getting they're they're not getting
along they're getting divorced
something's up with her you you find out
earlier that she's got something wrong
with her a tumor or something like that
i think you find that out early on in
the movie and so they're going on this
vacation you know they're going on a
vacation and they don't want to tell the
kids that they're going to get divorced
so that you know so they get to so they
you know and they make these veil
like really bad
it's bad writing choices of like making
reference to like getting older and you
know it's like it's so crazy right so
then they go to this beach this uh
resort and there's other people there
and they see them and they're like oh
hey what's up whatever and then the
people are like at the resort are like
oh you know they make this big show of
like here's your drink cocktails made
just for you and so the parents drink
the cocktails and the kids are like you
know and then the one kid like befriends
some kid who's at the at the resort
and they're walking around asking people
what they do and blah blah blah blah so
then uh you know the concierge guy of
the place is like hey we have a special
place we want to send you guys you know
it's a beach and you'll be there all day
all right so they get into a van and
this family goes to this beach and then
there's other people at the beach all
right and we'll talk about that
so
we get to the beach
and
so there's a okay so we meet some other
cast of characters so there's like an
older guy he's a doctor and he got a bad
young wife and they have a kid all right
and the wife
makes a show of saying
i have a calcium deficiency
so make sure i need you know i didn't
know why they were doing this at the
time but she's making a big show of
being like i have a calcium deficiency
and so they're on vacation with
their little girl
his mom him and you know and they're
there too so they're also on the beach
and then there's another couple asian
guy and a black woman and the black
woman
is getting seizures
so she has seizures so she makes a whole
thing out of dinner where she spills her
food and she's having a seizure and
everybody's like boom then the doctor
guy comes over and he's like looks at
her and he's like she'll be fine
whatever they're on the beach too
okay
and then who else is there and then when
we get there too there's this dude who's
like
a rapper
all right he's there
and he's got nosebleeds
and then there was some girl
that was there so there's a scene where
there's a girl she gets naked she's
obviously trying to be with the rapper
she goes out to the oceans to swim
and then we don't see anything of them
again they're all on the beach all right
so now they get to the beach as they're
going to the beach you know they get
there and then the guy is like and i
believe played by m like shyamalan
actually he's like he's like the the the
bus driver he go he gives them food he's
like a big thing of food and they're
like wow this is a lot of food why are
you giving us all this food and they're
like yeah well you know you'll be here
all day just you know better to have it
than not all right so they got all this
food there on the beach so now why
they're on this beach now stuff starts
to happen you know
stuff is starting to happen they got a
dog that also a dog is there with that
doctor family they got a dog so stuff is
starting to happen uh as you know the
movie is called old what's happening is
on this beach people age rapidly and
this is how they're finding out
so
the white girl that was with the black
the black guy the rapper she dead she
washes up on the beach and she's dead
now the doctor thinks that the black guy
killed her so now everybody's nervous
and they're like there's a dead body and
they're like let's get off this beach so
there's this like this cave that they
have to walk through to get back and
every time they try to walk through this
cave everybody passes out and they end
up back on the beach so that keeps
happening right so now as the movie
progresses you're like what's happening
and now it's just like and it's just a
lot of bad acting and like a lot of bad
indicating and like whatever you know so
now the kids start to grow so like the
kids are growing rapidly you know and
and you know
and as the camera angles are trying to
show you know that you know the little
boy's like my swimsuit doesn't fit
anymore and then like you know the the
parents you know the parents are looking
at them and they're like who the hell
are these kids i don't even recognize
these kids you know what i mean and then
it's they kids [ __ ] they just older now
so
so now you know the mom's like yeah you
better go use one of my bathing suits so
the little girl has her like bathing
suit and then the little boy is now not
a little boy because like the asian dude
and the black woman
they sitting there like how old are you
and you know you're seeing this from the
back back view of the kids onto the this
couple who are like looking at them like
so how old are you and the dude's like
he's 13 and he's all like i'm six you
know and they're like you're six you
know and then the other girl's like yeah
and i'm you know whatever 11 and she's
really 16 you know because of the
beaches age them so now now they know
something's up because now the parents
are like freaking out everybody's
freaking out because they're like what
the hell is going on you know what i
mean and [ __ ] is rapidly okay so now
everybody's elm everybody you realize
everybody's got an ailment actually
everybody on this beach got something
wrong with them okay
uh but the the black girl like i said
she was getting seizures she only has
one seizure
in this which is kind of odd i didn't
put my mind on it until later all right
the um
the doctor so the mom dies his old mom
his mom was already old she dies
okay dog dies all right
cut to
the black dude goes to look at the white
girl's body
that died he takes the blanket off of it
and the girl is now just bones because
she is decomposed so fast because you
age on this beach so now everybody's
like okay now they really realize and
now they realize what the hell is going
on they know we're aging
not just the kids but everybody's aging
so now it's a fight to try to get off
the beach
the the doctor
he sums up with his brain
you you come to realize he got dementia
or something and he's starting to go
crazy and he kills the black dude with
the with the knife because he's like
stay out of my neighborhood which was
kind of like
i thought i thought it was a little
racist you know like not
not but it's fine in within the story
you know what i'm trying to say but it
was it was just interesting that this
guy thought he was protecting his family
from this black guy
and he kills them all right so you got
that
so now they know that this guy's
dangerous so he's a danger to the people
on the island the wife is now
remember she said that calcium thing
she's starting to look crazy and she's
all like don't look at me you know what
i mean because she's hot as hell and now
she's
not hot anymore because she's aging and
her body is breaking down because of her
calcium thing okay
all right the little babe there was a
little girl the so that the hot ones
little girl is now not a little girl the
little boy who was six he's not a little
boy anymore so they're in the tent
together and now they're like teenagers
you know what i mean they're teenagers
and so they don't show it but cut two
they're walking back to where everybody
is and she's pregnant
like like full on six months pregnant
okay and then she
she has the baby it's a whole big
dramatic thing and then the baby dies
because the baby can't
the baby can't grow like it needed the
nourishment because apparently
every hour is like five years of your
life or something like that so i don't
know it's crazy so the baby dies
decomposes and that so that's that so
now they're dealing now they really want
to get off this island okay
so the girl
she tries to climb up the cliff every
time people try to swim or climb or go
through try to leave the island they
pass out so she tries to climb up the
cliff and she falls and breaks her neck
and so she's dead so now that girl's
dead who had the baby
now the parents of the two little kids
who are not little anymore
she oh she has a tumor and her tumor is
growing so her tumor you know
so
they
so like oh by the way like so when you
stab yourself or cut yourself you heal
instantly it just heals even if it's not
because of the rapidness of the the
island so this tumor is growing so the
doctor who now you know he's got
something wrong with him but he still he
cuts the the tumor out they have
operation because a woman passes out and
the tumor it goes from a golf ball to a
cantaloupe they pull the tumor out she
gets healed she heals and then she's
okay but she still ages and she's losing
her hearing the other guy the husband is
losing his eyesight so now the only
people left
are
the the hot chick who's like disgusted
with herself the dementia doctor
and this family of four they're the only
ones left the doctor's still going crazy
he tries to kill them
the the the wife stabs him with like a
rusty rusty knife so the rust poison
goes through his whole body and kills
him so he did
now he did
the kids are trying to escape in the
thing and then the
this was the stupidest scene so the the
wife that thought that it was hot she's
like in the cave and she keeps hitting
herself and so she breaks her arm right
she breaks her arm in a weird place and
it heals instantly in a weird place so
she breaks all her limbs and now she
looks like a spider and she's like you
know
crazy she dies
so now the two
the only people left are the brother and
sister and they're like 50 now okay so
they're 50. so they got some like
something in the story where they had
some like just the little kid from
earlier and him bonded and they had this
kind of like
cipher that they would like decipher
like a some a coded thing that you know
you match up the symbols and so the kid
left these guys a message saying
something about the coral like you can
escape in the coral basically what they
figure out so they swim
and then they also notice that they're
being watched so they're being watched
and observed so these
p the two brother sister they dive into
the coral you know to try to escape
and then you cut to up top you see
that it's some sort of scientific thing
they're watching them so then you start
to find out what the hell is going on
with this movie so
the
you cut to now
you're in like a laboratory
and then these people are kind of
celebrating they're like they're saying
hey moment of silence for a test group
whatever
come to find out that these people were
a test group
and these these scientists
are using this island as a way to test
medication
because you could give the medication to
someone
and then we could see
over
in one day la is in one day is really 20
years or 50 years you know what i mean
like one day is 30 years so they can
give somebody some medication and they
can test it and so they can save lives
that is the justification you know so
that little
that little drink in the beginning of
the movie was actually medication in it
for these people
whatever their ailments were so then you
cut back to and you realize oh the black
girl didn't have a seizure because they
gave her some experimental seizure
medication and so the people are like
celebrating because they're like it
worked because she didn't have a seizure
in eight hours which is equivalent to 16
years so that's gonna save lives you
know and so then they making this whole
discussion about like we shouldn't put
people with mental things because they
end up being violent this has happened
before so now you're just kind of like
what like like what is happening here
this is some kind of weird justification
to kill people so you're like all right
i get it
cut back to now the brother and sister
you think they drowned but they actually
they get to the resort one of the people
at the resort magically is a cop and
they go hey are you i hear you're a cop
and then they give them this like
notebook that they found on the beach of
all the people's names that were that
died and they're like oh yeah man we we
we're missing these people are missing
you know what i mean and so now the
place gets shut down
and that's the movie
and i was like
what
what am like shyamalan
shyamalan
it was just
it wasn't engaging
i just i think it was i think there were
some really great actors in this movie
that were wasted away on this nonsense
okay
the guy keeps trying to make
sort of spooky twisted like this was
supposed to be the twist because you
know every movie he's got a twist
and this was supposed to be the twist to
make you be like oh
that's what's happening it wasn't a good
one
i don't know man i don't know i hope he
gets it together and writes another gem
that we could be like ooh get that
feeling that we got but this ain't it
[Laughter]
so spoiler
alert recap of old
uh so you know that was like what we're
going to call old business you know so i
don't know man
that's my feeling on old
and uh yeah but we did it again y'all we
did it again live riffing with griffin
check me out in a little bit here
because i will be on eric griffin gaming
live on twitch and occasionally i put
those videos on eric griffin gaming on
youtube
that's my other youtube my other youtube
channel
i will be in edmonton this week so if
you if you're in the canada area you
want to come see me do some comedy come
out to edmonton and we'll check that out
but anyways this has been from with
griffin
please
like subscribe share
all that good stuff
i appreciate you for being here i love
the loyalty check me out on king of the
sting
check me out on jen to jen and check me
out on a podcast near you because people
like having me on and i like doing them
i appreciate you and i will see you
next week
[Music]
me
[Music]